hey guys so this is
behind the scenes
here before the set is even actually
built it's being built as i speak to you
right now look at this is insane
so much work
goes into one production this is the
social media station
i'm gonna be standing up here reading
tweets we have live polls we have a
what's spiking which is probably one of
my favorite things if you can see right
here
no we can't but it's an entire map of
the ces show floor
and it takes all of the tweets and all
the facebook posts and it'll show you
what everyone's talking about it's all
freaking live
technology is fantastic
so we're up here on top of this parking
garage you can see the convention center
right across the street you can see all
the people checking in getting their
badges and right below here is our
massive banner
we've been doing rehearsals all day oh
okay oh gosh
something's happening i almost died
right there it was a good chance my life
was in danger so yeah this is behind the
scenes you guys saw it yesterday when i
posted a video and it's coming together
so
quickly does people just build a
freaking set
let's build this
raw materials shoes that i'm wearing
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
walking very far in these
surprisingly they're pretty comfy uh
this is vegas kids this is it
by tomorrow this place is going to be
packed so uh i have a 30 on a 32. i'm
inside the show floor
am i even allowed to be filming in here
right now okay
i'm not filming in here right now but i
actually am
here
no no no no
okay this is m ms and mary do you need
to get your notebook are you okay is
this mine over here yeah there she is hi
how's it going hey vloggy
every time i've hybrid she's plugging
some twitter guys followers on twitter
please just tweet tweet it or instagram
me my favorites instagram now the same
name rich demiro dude instagram is
fabulous that's the best place to be
well thanks for joining us we've all
been waiting for you justin sorry i was
really busy on the show floor we can't
do the show without you that's jeff
justine is vital to this whole operation
and look at our view here have you i was
just gonna say look at this amazing view
it's unbelievable here it's like all
access set
we're gonna stay warm it's gonna be cold
it's gonna be real cold i'm gonna bring
a snuggie i might i brought my steelers
snuggie you're gonna bring a spike
well they didn't supply that
that
is happening right now
cool jay
all-star pact
and follow rich on twitter baby beetles
you could say baby bieber we don't know
but okay
the whale face meme that well we kind of
started it on instagram so basically you
like take a picture of yourself
you try to make it as disgusting as
possible like the uglier the photo the
better so like that's awful
you want to do a little whale face can
you come on just it's it's not supposed
to look good that's good that's going to
be up with him
no i got it like it's all right in this
guys post your wheelbase pictures on
instagram i want to see them i was going
and just liking everyone's pictures that
posted whale faces make sure you use the
hashtag and we'll see it oh it's done
yeah
it's good got it that's
good and the lower the camera angle the
more hideous it looks like it's bad
oh my god i'm so i'm so excited
you